what's going on reject nation Greg Alva
here and John Humphrey here so we saw
the movie Wonder Woman at a late showing
last night you betcha and we're here
today to finally talk about the film and
oh boy was Rotten Tomatoes wrong easily
the worst easy yeah okay woman with
sugar Oh women what can they do can they
do they do nothing yeah there's no
reason women didn't fight in the war
we're being sarcastic this is easily the
best needle you fell that far and away
and one of the best superhero films I
think I've ever seen actually I will
probably put it on the mantel with one
of the best superhero films I've ever
seen there's a great origin table it's a
wonderful origin tale of Wonder Woman
Diana Prince Princess Diana Prince's
which is called man the earth world I
mean my favorite thing about this some
word sort of seems was the themes we
share wisdom hope even its feminism
themes I thought we're all fantastically
played throughout this entire picture
for one I walked out of this film going
I wish I was a woman hello to the first
look I got because you're watching like
the Amazonians kicking ass or like oh
man oh no one of these chicks all right
here we go the whole island asses
because while there's like some CGI
infused in some of like the crazy stunts
a lot of it is just stuff women doing
legit crazy ass son leading off horses
all these crazy flips and wire effects
beyond the cool action scenes this is
that rare superhero film which is it's
weird to say because a lot of superhero
films touch on these themes but rare is
the day where I walk away with the
feeling of inspired to want to be a hero
more than just have superpowers I felt
like I want to be a hero and have faith
in humanity and to hope and the belief
yeah you don't leave with all the cool
junk you leave with the aspiration yes
it's about what you believe want to be a
better person see an opportunity to help
into
Yeah right because the story of Wonder
Woman is you know she's at this
crossroads in life she comes from this
land of denis kira kira hemisphere of
the Amazon warrior women who want
nothing to do with the real with the
outside world was going like at the six
with a world man this takes place during
World War one and Wonder Woman Diana
Prince is the only one who wants to know
leave the mascara and go help out and
fight against the war and help out
mankind I love that touch of it because
the odds are stacked against her in
terms of she doesn't really have the
backing of her family and then she goes
out into the real world where she just
kind of looked at as being a little
strange and offbeat and weird yeah I
mean she goes down into a situation that
that she doesn't really understand and
that's part of what's so great about
this is the movie really lets her learn
yeah throughout you know she goes in
with this very simple mission of like
I'm stop Ares and the war's gonna be
done yeah the whole movie is kind of
about her learning that that's not how
this works
you know it's a people thing that some
people are good and some people are bad
and it's not about just stopping one
thing that will prevent all evil well
that's part of what what I think is
terrific about this movie is the gray
areas and the nuances because a lot of
people complained about the BCE you not
understanding the spirit and tone of its
characters and I thought they translated
the the themes of heroism and what
heroism is made of really really
beautifully and it's really absolutely
absolutely and you know a lot of people
were thinking that it might have been
one of those it's not a true feminist
movie in terms of you know they some
people thought like they we'd walk out a
little bit or bed and we'll bitterly I
wouldn't happen
I mean feminism is about equality
feminism marrow and while like early
parts of the film kind of you know how
do you believing that it might be going
down that path in terms of how the
Amazon women sort of perceive what men
are like and a lot of us kind of funny
actually I don't how they first see what
they perceive meant to all men to be
like the movie doesn't leave you with
that impression at all I want to walk
away going man women are the best and
men are just horrible people well that's
part of the important contrast is that
you know when Steve Trevor washes up on
that
Beach they're all like no no no we
cannot man this is bad and Wonder Woman
is the one person's like no no no
there's some goodness guy like he's not
like all those other people were
shooting at you it allows characters to
make rum this idiot you know which is
important because yeah the whole theme
of it is hope and belief and manda
instilled in you that despite all the
darkness of there is in the world that
humming in on your life is so important
oh yeah I love that because I felt that
when I was watching the movie it wasn't
just told to me I felt there was about
tears to my eyes and then Kudus in the
direction by patty Jenkins in this film
yeah because she struck a beautiful tone
she did it like a seamlessly beautiful
tone where everything just blended well
together like the first 10 minutes are
rather serious is it it's all set up and
then when they start to infuse humor it
builds the humor it's like a little bit
here that a little more than a little
more than a lot more and then back in
the darkness and a little more he wasn't
back in there like it was so perfectly
told in terms of its feeling it's paced
perfectly well this script and and the
way the movie moves I really felt like
they thought of it in terms of like well
how would everybody react to the next
set of circumstances instead of where
does the plot need to go and how they
need to feel about that yeah instead of
having to be kind of confusing it
because you're going to go from set
mascara which is a totally different
looking world II you spend some good
time with which I'm really pleased do
today hopping to London during World War
one and then the battlefield in Germany
all these things when you're hopping
around to all these locations that look
very different from one another
I thought the cinematography did so well
where it didn't feel like though this is
like a totally different movie you know
what it transitions perfectly sort of
because all that time so not that
mascara is beautiful to look at and the
Amazon woman the Amazonian
are amazing those are some awesome
costing designs the women are badass and
a really diverse range of casting in a
way that's not in your in your face I
just kind of found myself noticing like
wow there are all kinds of people in
this movie out whether it's on Tennessee
era or earth you know yeah exactly
because they got real actors to do this
it was more than just let's have them be
two-dimensional Amazon badass chicks you
always understood the reasoning behind
any of their decisions or any of their
feelings behind any anything that went
on the movies not jam-packed with action
and that's what I what I really liked
this movie above all else feels like a
real movie and what I mean by it is like
it takes its time by the time it finally
gets to the first like real Wonder Woman
action sequence it's rewarding you oh
yeah yeah it's not like oh we have to
get an action scene because that's what
you guys want right it's like it earned
in early - because cares it's character
build up throughout everything more than
just Wonder Woman it's all the other
characters as well the first big action
scene is when Steve Trevor shows up and
then there's a fight that happens the
Amazonians and some soldiers and that's
a really well done action sequence it's
moving it's effective because you're
like oh this whole time they've been
moment in the world and now men are
showing up and they're this destroying
[ __ ] well that's the thing that makes
the action all the more potent in this
movie is that there's more things going
on than just up who do we have to fight
we're fighting but also there are
politics happening out of this because
you know we're of different places and
and as we get further into the movie
we're on you know in we're in regular or
thrown everyone's got their own idea
going on yeah so you're kind of
wondering how everyone's going to work
together I can only think of like three
maybe four big action sequences in the
movie off the top of my head because
most of it is just character scenes and
some of my favorite scenes are just
character scenes really could welder on
the topic of action I got to tell you
that whole sequence that you see in the
trailer where she's on the battlefield
the bullets are flying her she has a
shield the movie earned that battle
sequence so well so that by the time she
donned the outfit and is going on the
battlefield myself and I noticed
other people started to tear up an
action game of lottery I hate about it
again right now
I actually started gearing up as I was
so moved by her decision to go on the
battlefield when no one else was willing
to do it yeah really
earn that and that's what I mean is like
this action supports the plot the action
supports the character yeah it's not
real cool yeah
and that was something that made me so
happy inside without seeing there
especially during that scene going see
yeah you did it it works it works yeah
you can do it wonderful and the
choreography is so well done because you
know my brother pointed this out in his
review actually I thought I made a
really good point there which was about
how a lot of the times action movies
have this life really handhelds just
make it more realistic and what I love
shared the camera does move a lot but
you could always tell what's going on
pollies going at home and there are some
terrific patty Jenkins man the way she
shot that action is tremendous because
there are some teams were like those
camera choices are they're moving and
they're enhancing the action but you can
see everything and it's in Vickery
they're not all done the same food not
all the action scenes are the same way
yeah you could actually just distinctly
point out the differences from each one
of them and say this is what makes this
one different from this one this one
that they're not just like oh um repeat
the entire time and you always care why
they're fighting in theater like you
know in some of the previous movies
there are times where again if you don't
have enough character moments of
actually gets boring and I start to
think like okay when are you guys going
to be done punching each other so that
something else can happen one thing that
I've heard a lot of people make a
nitpick about was the use of slow-mo how
they thought it was a little overused I
personally didn't feel that way I
thought like it earned all the slow-mo
moments like in this was a good amount
of it I still thought it was always cool
who wouldn't have it yeah I couldn't see
why you might say that it just didn't
really bother me now you know no I
thought the moments they chose were cool
and and being this is a comic book movie
I thought all their frames were I was
like oh yeah that's like a comic book
panel it looks like there would be a
whoosh up here you know black or
something I also loved how in the action
moments how they
incorporate CGI in a great way a lot of
times a cc when the human beings are CGI
it's like they're CGI one shot and then
another shot they're back to human again
what I loved was how she they were able
to blend it were like oh she might do
this jump mercy CGI but then oh she's in
human form in the same shot yeah I
thought like it blended really well
yeah they got pretty good composites
going on I mean there are times when I
can tell like oh I can kind of see what
you probably did stitch this all
together it seemed like they put a lot
of effort into having things be on
camera for real you know there are
certain things that get CG diff you have
to but I didn't think it was way too
much or no never in this movie I thought
they used it correctly let's go to the
characters finally Yami done man I've
said it before I was doubtful when I
first heard she was cast as Wonder Woman
I was ever bothered by her physical
appearance
I never was because I was like Wonder
Woman has super strength
it doesn't matter here like oh yeah
that's how it goes off to match them and
I don't know why I do I understand on
the one hand but also you know there's
such a thing as movie magic
I believe me about performance we made
John rhys-davies who's really tall into
a short dwarf and lore there and you can
kind of do anything yet with at least
physique yeah and gal gadot her
performance is so multi-layered
in this film - um far from OneNote every
character quality is is present in every
oh she's a bully multi-layer dimensional
character from the sense of yes the
warrior asked whether struct is great
there you believe her when she's kicking
ass she pulls off the stunt work really
well the action sequences really well
her determination
her faith her hurt hurt her that was the
big part of it that hurt
always the hurt was a big part of her
character how she felt so much for the
people and I never thought of it in a
cheesy way I always believed she really
cares about people oh yeah thank you
hurt for the cause because that's the
thing is like you know and yet Alek days
it's it's easier to feel that with the
world the way
you know you really feel like man the
drive and passion of someone who just
wants to help is a move van thing you
know especially when the circumstances
are overwhelming and hard to understand
it's a passionate performance his
intended passionate performance and in a
sense of wonder when she's a fish out of
water in a lot of these scenarios is
fantastic - you know she pulled up the
comedy elements really well she has a
really unified to the end like she
really does feel like she had a fully
developed character and she brings so
much charm and so much life to it yeah
she inspired me she did by tummy yeah
you know I could you want to beat her as
a guy I'm watching I'm like I won't be
this person when on the thing coin Steve
Trevor kind of did the tape I killed it
yeah he killed it he that's the only of
strength we killed in a movie like the
and their chemistry both as performers
but also in the air ripped is tremendous
like the interplay between Diana Prince
and Steve Trevor
is one of the best things about this
yeah in a movie full of things that are
great you know like that is one of the
best on-screen duo lifting a long time I
don't know exactly what Steve Trevor is
like in the comics per se when he first
meets Diana what I loved about the
choice the writing here was they didn't
make him uh what's the word they make
him a womanizer they didn't make him
star-lord yeah I think Star Trek I think
he's really funny he's a little more
energetic more upbeat you know here he's
more subtle but he's still really funny
multi-layered I love that his character
is in such support and non-judgmental of
who diana is and he's the last thing
from being a womanizer he's actually
quite respectful it stands up for her
and always has her back but the
relationship has developed like yeah
okay obviously you could just see the
truth and see this developing into a
romance but I gotta tell you guys the
morning bill I just kept believing in
him and I like romance kept going I felt
the love they were developing for each I
felt it well yeah because they develop a
relationship based off of both kind of
intrigue it also respect over time
because it variances yeah it's not just
ah gotta have a roll man this movie's a
black
I was in love with Breanna now whatever
they make sense that they would start to
develop strong feelings for each other
yeah and it lets them both be right and
wrong and sometimes less than both have
a point and by the end of it you
naturally feel like wow after all you've
been through I can see what resonates
between you guys and why you would
actually care about each other yeah so
you know the best scenes are just them
talking with each other and it sells
those coincidence things you know that
much more it's like this is the guy who
washed up on the beach but it works yeah
I mean there's like a great scene where
the end of talking about sex there's a
great scene where they're dancing
they're like yeah it isn't the moment to
take time to let them talk with each
other or some of the best moments in
this mood well that's what elevates
these films is when you allow the
characters to have even just a little
bit of life you don't have to make it an
indie drama but you know in a few
minutes you can have a really
heartwarming scene that makes us care
that much more about the plot is
concerned with I mean there's other
characters in there too that I thought
were fantastic the supporting cast is
great Robin Wright as a general Antioch
which is the one who trains Diana she's
like Diana's aunt in the movie and she's
not in the film for that long she'd
stand out caring for a woman who doesn't
really have that much screen time she's
like she's one of the characters I
thought about well my movie was done of
this strong performance of a character
that I don't really want to go into and
I'm not worth it because she's barely in
the film but I could tell you guys Matt
agresa
has a powerful performance on her and
Bobby and Connie Nielsen into the Queen
Hippolyta's welcome poetess Greek at the
bottom hip hop a pot of the lyrics to
the bottom list and everyone's so
multi-layered
in this film yeah everyone no one is a
one-dimensional performance you get her
mom's reasoning for what she doesn't
want Diana to fight well as she will let
Diana make certain decisions why should
we'll let her learn to train why she
won't let her train every single
decision was very much understood you
can always feel that there was a full
backstory behind every performance does
it a lot of try to go to the
screenwriting as well for it as well the
writing always varies in these and I
feel like this movie again finds a nice
a really perfect pitch between having a
great cast who can
the acting chops to put nuance under the
words but also I feel like this is a
pretty good example of good studio
writing work yeah there there is plot
dialogue but it is also immersed in an
understanding of its characters yeah
even if scenes are short and they're
giving you information you're also
learning about how the characters feel
and they feel like real people because
of that yeah he's a little easy to
overlook that that stuff in a superhero
movie that's one of the reasons why I
was so upset about that members of
Superman because none of those
characters got to have character and you
need that if we're ever gonna care and
this movie achieved that with flying
colors that's what it was the best thing
about this movie and it can't even care
about the one is like Steve Trevor
secretary she's awesome she's all arias
she's hilarious
oh yeah I always enjoy her whether it's
like chronic dead or Mariner that she's
so funny I love her like I love her
admiration for Steven her admiration for
Diana when she meets her like right away
like she wouldn't you over in a
heartbeat
yeah is so quick that you wouldn't do
over that first thing I'm like I I want
to watch like just like a serial comic
strip memory of you the main villains
that are being focused on in the film
Danny Huston as general Eric do didn't
erich ludendorff he does a good job I
mean I'm kind of used to this guy just
being bad I think Danny Huston is a good
actor and I think he brings something to
it I'm kind of with you it's not like oh
wow I've never seen him do this before
but I think he does it well in this
movie and I liked watching him yeah and
they did some different moments with
them that enhance I mean they are I'd
have any character to be kind of
two-dimensional that's not really fully
multi-layer it really is him there was
mainly the writing on him they didn't
really give him much to do the showed
multi-layer he is kind of just bad
German guy yeah we kind of check in on
her to remain Duss how evil he is and
then we check that yeah - Wonder Woman
and then the other villain and later on
a Yahoo plays doctor poison I thought
the writing of doctor poison honestly if
I have I only have like a couple of
nitpicky issues with this film I didn't
really like her performance I'm going to
be completely honest I did it really
I could always see what she was going
for and I thought out of any of the
characters that have multi-way and the
villains
I thought she would had more layers to
her especially in later scenes in the
movie where you start seeing other
aspects and qualities to her however I
did you really believe I guess I can see
where you're coming from I mean I liked
her performance I always wanted a little
bit more I guess is what I left her
scenes with like I liked what I was
getting and I always hoped for a little
bit more of that it didn't really affect
me while I was watching the movie last
night for the first time but you know
thinking back on it both her and Danny
Huston I could have maybe used a little
bit more on them yeah a little bit more
nuance on them or something because of
all the characters they're the one to
get to have evil plans and cackled about
yeah also the actor David Thewlis is in
the cell if you haven't read any news
reports on your David Thewlis is playing
don't get it so I'll totally ruin the
movie for you yeah it ruins an important
part of how the story unfolds and I have
no idea what they were thinking yeah
ants are like realizing that as
announcement yeah I feel like they
announced that and whoever did that
didn't read the script exact look at the
team that forms when Steve Trevor and
Wonder Woman are going to go to the
front to be able to fight the Germans
and you know take down at the general
the team that forms is really good Oh
we'll go more some in the spoiler review
of who they are they have a character
Sameer who's the master of disguise you
got Charlie to heavy drinking Scottish
guy Chuck she's the sniper gun
Trainspotting you get the Native
American guy chief and the whole team
there is really good too and that's the
thing is like this is a pretty diverse
movie in a way that is not at least to
me wasn't just in your face about it
just like everyone oh wow
this is a diverse cast and I only picked
up on it yeah partway through yeah we're
not in your face it's like it just seems
like this is the team yeah great I
understand why you're all here you've
all got a personality like I enjoy
watching oh absolutely you brought this
up
we were just hearing about rotten
tomatoes giving a high score how she's
been very public patty Jenkins about
saying her main inspiration for this was
the themes of Superman Richard Donner's
movie and she succeeds in that she later
succeeds enough and that and that whole
vibe of it because you do get all the
sense of heroism an inspiration that you
have where you don't really feel in
superhero movies anymore yeah you you
get the themes that arguably you're
supposed to have you know I feel like
you've lost a lot to being gritty and
anti-heroes but I feel like you can do
that without losing all beginning this
film and the other thing to the finale
that I'm sure you've heard a lot of
people say how it gets really CGI heavy
and it falls under some typical comic
book territory where it gets all big and
crazy all the sudden and expositional
one and revealed and while oh yeah
that's there it's definitely there I
wouldn't say it never didn't I didn't
lose the film they don't lose me though
the feeling of like by the time the the
big finale comes to film has done so
many graphing that at that point you
know it's fine it even in the finale
though there's still great great action
moments or so great character moments I
still cried at something that happens in
the finale well I read the big [ __ ] HD
now while I do think DC in each of their
movies kind of has demonstrated this
problem when you get to the big finale
fight the action and the physics of
everything are so much bigger than the
rest of the movie you know Man of Steel
was like that BBS is like that Suicide
Squad is like that this movie has the
least of that but I kind of agree with
what you said it's like I feel like the
third act could have been a bit smoother
with just an extra scene yeah you know
between her and the big bag just to kind
of help it to feel a little left like it
kind of ramped up the action but yeah
like you said there's some great stuff
in that scene I like the designs that
they like when it's still rewarding
there's any know it's huge and big and a
little CGI distracting there's still
some really cool stuff that happens and
you have fire to them and there was no
meaningful stuff going on and seeing
exactly number one I was still moved in
the finale and still cried a certain
part in this analysis yeah the movie
never just takes a break from being a
movie to kick an ass
yeah that's kind of a wonderful yeah it
didn't it's like while I have to jam
pack a certain amount into definitely it
still didn't feel like you're rushing
now this movie has similarities to other
superhero movies you'll think of you
know maybe the First Avenger you might
think of Thor you might think of subra
yeah Superman but the thing is like I
said before this the heart and nuances
of this movie are all its own even a
certain plot elements are reminiscent
every one of these movies has those
unless you're talking about maybe like a
loli or a Dark Knight where they're not
trying to make this specific kind of
superhero yes but as far as this kind of
you know sort of the spandex goes I
think they they did a beautiful job of
demonstrating the fact that you can have
all that fun stuff and also make a real
movie out of it and I there's there's
very little Justice League Universe
tie-ins into this film very little and
we'll go into it in the spoiler review
yeah but in this movie I love how they
like by the time the judge the like when
they have the tie in because the first
thing the tie and Tapani or like other
it is but then when it comes back as
like meaningful oh yeah and it supports
the whole story we just watched it makes
an impact the first time the tie-in
popped up that was kind of my least
favorite thing and then yeah it sort of
in when it comes back and work on early
what earned itself younger okay yeah
this is sort of fitting and I do again I
do appreciate especially on the heels of
something like that men V Superman where
it was clear to me that they're not
focused so much on this movie as they
are focused on the next movie that's how
they treat em everything this movie
makes the smart choice of focusing on
this or to jail and this character and
making sure we do everything right right
now and we don't have to fix it later
yeah exactly and that's what you should
do if were if you're going to spend that
much money on a movie like this you need
to do that yeah this movie was one of
the best superhero movie a very long
I'm definitely one of the best congra
movies ever I I would give it to give it
a you know 5 out of 5 Gregg's dude I
have like tears in my eyes for most of
this shows cry I cry I could shoot on
Twitter air just nibbling like a lot it
is mostly moodling honestly like is
especially just kind of a whole first
act no man wears a good look a few
breaks laughs see I give this you know
the 600 jonov and you know 10 golden
lasses of true alright well you can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell dad light on Humphrey
on Twitter and Instagram go check out
our page around for all of exclusive
goodies and do it exclusive fun random
video content over there yeah thank you
can look out for our spoiler video which
will see a little green screen something
for that one yeah a little change with
the background make a little more
interesting